I'm so glad that some of our
conversations are on meditation so I
have a number of questions that are I
get on meditation uh what time there are
just many many many types of meditation
and I suppose they're probably almost
all good I've only experienced
Transcendental Meditation but there's uh
the type of meditation that I do is a
mantra Transcendental Meditation I think
there are a number of them that have
mantras and the way it works is there's
a sound that you repeat in your mind
that takes your thoughts away from your
thoughts and puts them into that sound
for example oh might be an example and
you repeat and you sit there quietly and
you repeat and the greatest problem
you're going to have is impatience
you're going to go into that state of
meditation and you're going to get
restless and that tells you you need to
meditate because if you can't sit there
and transcend and get rid of your
thoughts you're going to be in trouble
and think about the power that you have
when you can go into that nothingness
and experience that it's like going on
vacation and also being given the gift
of creativity and Equanimity how did I
learn to meditate The Beatles taught me
not I mean not literally what they did
is they went to India and they came back
and they told everybody about
Transcendental Meditation and I thought
well okay that sounds cool I'll try it
and so I went to
um a place a little townhouse where they
uh taught meditation I brought my
flowers I paid my fee and so on and I
learned then Transcendental Meditation
and you know thank God for it so when do
I meditate I meditate usually in the
morning before breakfast usually in the
evening before dinner I tried to not
always faithful to that and then also
when I have the need you know I could
feel the difference between being
centered and having that Equanimity and
not when there's stress when there's
tensions when there's big things
sometimes Weighing on me and I uh then
no I just need to go meditate and I can
go into some quiet spot and be there for
20 minutes and it just goes all off me
all that and then I come out of it and I
have a Clarity and an Equanimity that
lets me deal with whatever it is